let's uh talk one more time with uh my
uh my friend from nfl films senior
producer whose eye
on the eye in the sky never lies he is
greg cosell's back here on the rich
island show how are you greg cosell
rich i'm doing great you know you
probably know this you know what today
is the 50th year anniversary of the 50th
year anniversary
of what is the night celebrating 1966
1971 what one what is that greg what is
it
it would be the release of sticky
fingers one of the greatest albums of
all time
ah look at you greg look at you going
pop culture off the back
you know i think you would know that
rich i know you're a renaissance man
i did not i didn't i turned to my nfl
uh my audio executive mike deltufa
normally you keep me apprised of this
sort of stuff i am i
i you've dropped the ball it's okay i
did
it sorry greg i was listening to it this
morning watching tape you know
is that is that how you watch tape where
do you watch tape walk me through that
process
i watch tape in my office at nfl films
i've got a tv screen you know i've got
my
cowboy remote you know so i sit and
watch tape it's a beautiful thing
i listen to music and it depends on my
mood but today was it when i
saw that it was a sticky fingers mode
you know fantastic
how many players have you watched tape
on greg about 180 185 maybe
okay so before we get to the the
quarterbacks uh one last evaluation
atop that uh is kyle pitch the most
uh talented player that's not a
quarterback or even of all of the
players that you've seen
on facebook i personally believe he's
the best prospect in this draft yes
would you go trade up and go get him if
you're the dallas cowboys at 10. flat
out right out the door what do you think
greg
what do you think yeah i think i mean i
think with pitts you have to
it doesn't matter what two letters you
put before or after his name
i think he's a receiver and he's a
weapon and i think he changes the way
you can play offense
and makes it easier for your quarterback
the way it makes it easier is it gives
you more formation variation
you can do more things with what we call
receiver distribution and location
which means the number of receivers to
each side of the formation
and who those receivers are that's the
location and it gives the quarterback
more information before the ball is
snapped
and that's what every coach is trying to
do they're trying to give the
quarterback the answer to the test
before the ball is snapped
of course of course you're trying to do
that and he's you're able to do that but
what on what on tape did you see that
makes makes you go
this is how how good he he is and how it
can be translated to the next level
well his movement rates are off the
charts he's such an
easy natural mover he's fluid
he can change direction he's got
incredibly long arms
which allows him to make contested
catches very easily
he can run he's such an easy runner he
caught a touchdown this year against
kelvin joseph a corner from kentucky
who has first-round traits where he was
uh
um the line of scrimmage tight end and
he just ran
kind of a routine uh not quite an
inbreaker but he caught the ball
against joseph after making a very good
move and he just kind of ran away from
him and we're talking about a corner
so you're dealing with a kid that can
win at all three levels
he's tremendous in the red zone not only
with his hands and his ability to go up
and get the ball
but also with his ability to change
direction he runs those wide receiver
routes
those those change of direction routes
like pivot routes
whip routes routes we associate with
slot receivers
slot receivers not even guys outside the
numbers slot receivers you're saying
yes so i mean he's to me he's i've been
doing this a long time rich as you know
you know i finished 41 years at nfl
films this season so i've seen a lot of
players and i tend sometimes to be jaded
but this kid to me is really special
greg cosell here on the rich eisen show
so then there's the wide receiver class
um
the bengals are going to have that
choice i believe between jamar chase
to uh to give joe burrow a weapon
with whom he's most familiar uh or
penne sewell uh a protector what based
on the the film that you see
what would you say is the the better
option at five
for the bengals that that's a hard call
only because
that becomes a philosophy issue i mean
how you feel about
protection how you feel about your
quarterback being able to handle
and at times perhaps camouflage a lesser
o-line
many quarterbacks can camouflage
whole-line weaknesses
or lack of strength in an all-line with
the way in which they play with timing
and rhythm
i also may think burrow is that guy
jamar
chase to me is another guy that has some
special qualities
um he's a type a personality he's an
alpha dog
he's got great great when i say size not
not length per se but the way he's built
his play strength is is really high
level body control
balance you know he reminded me of two
guys
when i watched him and normally these
things just pop into my head rich i
don't sit around
for 15 minutes after i watch a guy and
say who does he remind me of it either
pops into my head or it doesn't
but he reminded me in the way in which
he played of steve smith and deandre
hopkins
those are two pretty damn good receivers
i'll tell you that
yeah no i i he's another guy whose tape
i like and obviously i watched his 2019
tape um
his tape in my view was really really
good okay and then what about the
wide receivers from alabama how would
you rank them
uh and i guess you have to also include
the fact that the nfl
usually just looks at somebody who's 166
pounds as the
heisman trophy owner devonte smith is
and just say well that alone means
you can't be in the top part of this
draft well i didn't
i'd answer that question this way i
would say that what that means is that
devonte smith is a discussion in draft
rooms
it doesn't mean he can or can't play but
it's a discussion because he's an
exception
so you have to discuss it now you may
come away from that discussion and say
it doesn't matter
his receiving traits are so good which
they are by the way
that we feel that that can compensate
the fact that
he's 166 pounds or you may come away and
say
depending on your view and say you know
what we're a little concerned about that
we love the player
but we're a little concerned so i i
think when all said and done
you ultimately have to decide how best
to deploy him
um my sense is that you'd probably
deploy him as what we call an
off the ball receiver meaning he's in
he's a z
that he doesn't line up right on the
line of scrimmage where if he
if he's pressed the corners literally
right there next to him
that if he's off the ball there's a
little more room between him and the
corner and
that receiver the z he can go in motion
because to me what you want to do with
the with avonte smith
is you want to get him free access off
the ball he's
silky smooth and he's a strider you want
to allow him to stride out
in the initial part of his routes that's
where he's so good
he's so good when he can stride out and
then
it gets into the rest of his his
receiving traits
but you don't want him to have to fight
off press coverage
too often i'm not saying he can't do it
but i don't think that's what you want
to do with them too often
nfl films senior producer greg cosell
here on the rich eisen show nfl matchup
analyst as well at greg cosell on
twitter i follow him you should
as well the best defensive player in
this draft is fill in that blank
we got something oh the best defensive
player god
um to
um throw out some names to me i've seen
so many guys okay you got
parsons you got um you got patrick
certain
at the corner just those are two choices
right off the back jc horn is another
one that the cowboys are apparently
i would say it really intrigues me
because the thing about if you're going
to look at linebackers
in today's nfl to draft the linebacker
high in my view he has to be
able to play in your sub defenses
meaning 5 db
6 dbs either as a coverage player space
player or as a pass rusher
now many people may not know that micah
parsons when he was recruited out of
high school
many recruited him as a defensive end
that's what he played in high school
he has pass rush traits um he is a
really explosive athlete and he's close
to 250 pounds
there's not a lot of guys close to 250
who have his kind of explosive movement
traits
so he's got special movement traits
um he's a fascinating player and then
like i said
you you play in your sub defense and he
can be either a linebacker playing in
space
matching up to tight ends or he can rush
the quarterback because
he has experience in his background
doing that
greg cosell here on the rich eisen show
let's get to the quarterback evaluation
your last one for us before we get to
the to the draft we've seen all the pro
days now a couple of them have had
multiple pro days
uh the tape on trey lance is two years
old because
uh 2019 was the last year in which he
played we all know about the evaluation
about mack jones and what he has
suddenly become in terms of
uh the apple of the 49ers eye supposedly
after the trade and then justin fields
and now
lance's uh on that carousel as perhaps
being the one that the 49ers traded up
to third overall there's also zach
wilson for the jets
walk me through your quarterback depth
chart what do you got for me
six days before the trial i i think and
i'll answer it this way
i think we've reached the point in the
nfl
where everybody ascribes
the same traits they have the same
traits cheat for quarterbacks
it's just the relative value you would
ascribe to different traits so in other
words
some coaches might believe we're now at
the point where you're limited to not
being a great
starter if you can't make plays off
script
other coaches might say you know what
that's a good thing to have
but at the end of the day here's i teach
my system it's a structured system
because all quarterbacks are system
quarterbacks they're taught a system
and if you can't execute my system to
the highest level
the rest doesn't matter so it's
ultimately where you
fall on that we know how kyle shanahan
and of course
who he drafts is unanswerable right now
but
we know kyle shanahan is tremendous
conviction in his system right rich
you know we all know that about kyle so
does he is he looking for someone who he
believes
will execute it to its highest level
or has he evolved and is he looking for
someone who yes
he can teach them how to execute it to
its highest level
but also would love to have that ability
to make some off-script plays
because seemingly they happen in every
game
that's that ultimately to me is the
question
and it we it's unanswerable right now
mack jones has a lot of great traits no
question
he will not make off-script plays and
and
what you're trying to do with those
kinds of quarterbacks is they have to be
special in the pre-snap phase as we said
have the answers to the test
and they have to have tremendous
functional knowledge of defenses
knowing which particular defenders are
critical based on
a given play call so
what are you you've looked at all the
tape yeah
i don't know if you have like one
through five but if you well i really
don't but i'll tell you the guy who i
i s in in re-watching who
i'm starting to like more and again i
don't know him and i don't know where
he'll go
but uh justin fields has really grown on
me i think he's got a lot of really good
traits
um and i'm really curious to see where
he goes how
has he grown on you greg cosell um i
i really like the way he throws the ball
uh to quote a coach that i know he's got
a 65 plus yard arm
so he can drive the football i think
he's got a power arm
i think he can throw with touch and pace
um
you know i just i just think that in
some ways it's the justin herbert
conversation from a year ago
were there some concerns on tape with
herbert yes there were
because that's all we had as of a year
ago could you say that about fields
sure um but i think he's really a high
level traits quarterback
and we just don't know or i don't know
anyway um
why herbert why those things that were
on tape that were not necessarily
positive
didn't show up this year it maybe it's
just natural development of the player
maybe it was coaching
maybe it's any number of reasons but
that's why i'm so anxious to see where
field's goal
goes because i just think he has high
level traits i mean last we spoke greg
cosell it was after
just after the trade it happened and i
asked you who do you think that they
they traded up to go get and that's
where we first had that conversation
that we just just
you know revisited about your concept of
what do you want you want somebody who
doesn't
who's going to stick to the script and
you're so darn confident in your script
and in your
your scheme that that's the perfect guy
for you or you're going to want somebody
who can actually give you those
unscripted plays and that's the question
that's going to be posed to kyle
shanahan with the
the uh the question in the form of who's
your third overall pick right
so yeah it's unanswerable right now
obviously but i think that's part
of the question and that's a discussion
you have to have that discussion
before you draft a quarterback but now
we also know
in between that point and this point
greg cosell that the jets
have decided that one of these kids in
this draft is a better option than sam
darnold moving forward
and we're assuming it's zach wilson if
that's the case do you like that
evaluation that the jets did
and and going in that direction um
you know boy yes and no i mean i
donald was a guy that look i thought he
had some concerns coming out
and clearly those concerns continue to
show up through
his first three years in the league he's
now going to be in what's essentially a
kyle shanahan system where everything is
really well defined
it's impossible to know how we would
have handled that we're not going to see
him
in that specific system um
you you i think there's more that goes
into it than just on field play here
because i think
an organization now gets a chance to
reset itself rich
when you draft a quarterback where they
were in a tough spot with darnold
because if they kept
arnold first of all the fan base
probably would not have been happy
and if darnold went out week one and and
was over three on his first three passes
we know how that would go
so uh if you're just talking from purely
a talent level
um i think wilson presents a little bit
more than darnold has
um but you know wilson is not a big
quarterback you don't have to be a big
quarterback you know we've seen that
but wilson moves around a lot there's a
lot of
patrick mahomes and wilson in that
there's a
based on pure college tape i'm speaking
now we know what mahomes has become
there's a little bit of an undisciplined
reckless nature to wilson and i'm
curious to see
how that plays out within a highly
structured system
that he will now be taught if that's who
the jets pick
and you know uh usually when a first
overall
selection gets his uh fifth year option
picked up
it's not uh a big bit of news but this
is baker mayfield we're talking about
now and that's apparently what the
browns have done
um and and we had kevin stefanski on the
show
yesterday it seems like that those guys
are are appropriately matched at the hip
they're meshing very well
uh do you agree with that decision and
also the the
caroline is apparently uh going to wait
till after the draft to pick up
darnold's fifth year option which means
they might actually choose one eight or
give the indication to somebody you
better come up and trade with us
because we might take your guy that
might be an interesting scenario right
there
well as far as baker i agree with that i
think that he improved dramatically
again i think this is why there's so
many variables because i think the kevin
stevansky system
which starts with play action and i
think that play action really helps to
find reads and throws for a quarterback
i think that really helped baker it was
evident watching the tape that he
became more confident as the year
progressed they started to throw the
ball more later in the season
so yes i think with that system and that
system has really done well for a lot of
quarterbacks it's
essentially a similar system it has
elements of course of the gary kubiak
system
and we saw for instance what gary kubiak
did for three four years with matt
schaab and houston you know it really
presents
i hate to use the term that it's
quarterback friendly because it's so
cliched
but quarterback friendly means certain
things that it presents defined
reads and throws based on the structure
of your offense the use of personnel
the use of formations what that means
for the predictability of defense
there's so many things that go into it
and i think that it really helped baker
mayfield and he clearly
was a comfortable quarterback as the
year progressed greg
always enjoy our chats i tweeted out the
last time i could talk ball with you all
day
um i really could but i have to take a
break and make sure that my uh partners
get their commercial time um
i appreciate it let's talk after the
draft if you don't mind i always you
know
i love you rich right back at you thanks
greg thanks
you bet that's greg cosell i follow him
you should too
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here